make tyra proud and just prune like one
of the Olsen twins
I feel like posing on red carpets is a
lot of hands on the hip that's what I
would do
everyone seems to look perfect on the
red carpet I don't know how people are
able to look so good when they're
wearing these crazy outfits which
they're like definitely sweating in and
most celebrities don't sweat I'm doing
the seated pick which I'm a little
uncomfortable about because I'm wearing
like a pretty tight shirt and I'm like
sitting on this we're done so I have no
idea maybe like arch my back or sit up
straighter I have the headshot today so
from the chat stop and just focusing in
on the moneymaker I just don't know how
you look so good under so much pressure
I am doing the full-body shot which is
always the one that can go wrong because
you never know where to put your hands
your face just have so many things to
worry about at one time I was assigned
the candy food it's actually harder than
it looks kind of walked back and forth
while candidly looking at the camera
it's like your fitting so many different
hot people in one photo I feel it's
overwhelming I mean with Ellen selfie I
needed to put my phone down for five
minutes and just type you can pose and
like have a drink my name is Lindsay
Albanese I'm a celebrity wardrobe
stylist and I have a fashion YouTube
channel where I share all of my tips but
today I'm going to help some people
perfect their pose mm-hmm the key when
doing a seated shot is in the legs and
in the arm you did one thing really
right you cross the legs I always yeah
because you know we want to minimize our
thighs when we sit like this it's like
so you just kind of put your rest your
arm here on your your forearm on your
leg and then you're just gonna kind of
lean out a little bit the natural you
that everyone wants to see so I was
tasked with doing a head shot I'm always
caught between like do I go full-on
serious do I go like full-on smile and
then it ends up looking like there's
like a like bad diaper underneath my
nose so the key is to kind of look away
and then look at the camera
and then take a deep breath and smile as
you exhale for a candid shot oh very
candid everyone loves a photo that looks
candid and like it was captured in the
moment let's just do you know anything
you would naturally do in life like how
would you hang out with your friends
yeah your knees are buckle that's what I
do all the time or a signature pose is
all in the leg language and the posture
so what you're always gonna do you're
gonna bend one knee pop the hip out a
little bit and own it feels nicer I feel
sexier already the key to getting this
right is when everyone huddled together
kind of like look around to see what
people are doing and then do the
opposite and get comfortable and cozy 1
2 3
I think we all learn how to be a little
bit sexier today